water carries so much information in
just one drop
[Music]
today we're in Lake Huron we came
specifically to explore cyanobacteria
which is also known as blue green algae
which were the first organisms to start
producing oxygen on our planets
there is this Unique Kind of
cyanobacteria known as Purple
cyanobacteria we don't know much about
their chemistry what kind of molecules
they could be making are they toxic are
they beneficial to us
so we came to get some samples and
uncover their genetic makeup as well as
their chemical profile to try to get to
some of these sensors
the bottom of Lake Huron is actually old
ocean floor and so this is just as
prized as things that we see in
Yellowstone hot springs and Arctic Lakes
so that we can study how Earth became
habitable
my work as an Explorer and a scientist
relies on water transportation sometimes
I cannot go to a space if I'm in a big
boat and I need something more personal
and smaller
writing a Sea-Doo allows me to get
closer to the wildlife that I'm studying
[Music]
I go
back to when I was really young I
actually used to be very scared to go
into deep water
because I semi drowned when I was a kid
I grew up in Peru in between the city
the jungle and the Andes to go visit
family in remote areas in the jungle we
had to be in water like that was the
only method of transportation so it was
an inherent need to want to overcome
that
he went from being a fearful experience
to being a very nurturing one
[Music]
once we collect samples we immediately
want to take a look under the microscope
so we can understand how they live in
their natural environments how they
behave then we can take those samples
into the lab and do more complex
experiments to gather more information
from them
oh look at that one
the samples we collected today are just
one piece of a much bigger puzzle
based on previous experience we predict
the novel molecules found in purple
cyanobacteria might lead us to
breakthroughs in medicine and
sustainability
taking the dive into the unknown is the
only way we can discover more about
where we came from as a species and how
we can protect our planet
[Music]
remember that everything is connected
what you do impacts life on the other
side of the world sometimes even though
you may not see it
that's what drives me just unlocking all
of that knowledge I really think that
has been the missing key in better
conserving Earth
water connects everything
[Music]